in the last video I told you that for
quadratic function for a quadratic
function that the change in the change
of Y is constant what I mean that what I
mean by that this is what we did in the
last video this was a quadratic this was
data from a quadratic function that when
X increased from 1 to 2 y increased by 2
that when we increased X from 2 to 3 y
didn't increase at all it increased by 0
so the change in Y was clearly not
constant and then we went from 3 to 4 Y
actually decreased by negative 2 so the
change in Y was not constant but the
change in the changes of Y we had a
change in Y of 2 then a change in Y of 0
so our change in the change of Y was
negative 2 then we went from a 0 to a
negative 2 so the change in the change
of Y was negative 2 what I want to do in
this video is show you why that works
for a quadratic function and just to
make the math simple I'm gonna pick the
simplest of quadratic functions and if
you have some free time on your hands
you might try it out for the more
general case but I'm going to try to
show you that it works for Y is equal to
x squared and you could try it later
with ax squared plus BX plus C and I'm
going to increment X by 1 it this will
work as long as you increase X by a
constant amount but one makes the math a
little bit simpler so let's pick some
X's so let's pick some X's and I'm going
to keep things a little bit general so
it's gonna be very abstract an algebraic
e for a little bit but I think you might
find it satisfying and then we'll figure
out our wise given the X so let's say
that X is X 1 so when I write this
little subscript 1 here that means I'm
picking a particular X a particular
example of the variable X a particular X
in the domain of this function so in
that situation what's y going to be
equal to well Y is just going to be
equal to X 1 squared let me do that in
orange keep the colors consistent X 1
squared
now let's say we increment X by 1 so our
next one is going to be X 1 plus 1 I'm
just going 1 above that
over there if this was three this is
going to be four and this was zero this
is going to be one then this is going to
be x1 plus one squared which is equal to
x1 squared plus two x one plus one all
right let's increase this by one so then
we get to x1 plus two if this is 0 this
is 1 this is 2 if this is 10 this is 11
this is 12
so then why when we have this x value
will be x1 plus 2 squared which is equal
to x1 squared plus 4x1 plus 4 let's do
live into 2 more actually now let's
increase by another one I think you see
what I'm doing
x1 plus 3 when the Y value and X when X
is x1 plus 3 is going to be x1 plus 3
squared which is equal to x1 squared
plus 6x 1 plus 9 let's do one more so
when X is going to be let's increment it
by one more x1 plus four Y is going to
be x1 plus four squared which is equal
to x1 squared plus eight X 1 plus 16 now
given this let's figure out the changes
in Y so let me write here the change in
Y the change in Y as we increment X by 1
each time so here the change in Y will
take this point or this Y value minus
this Y value if we take this Y value
minus this Y value so from here to here
our change in Y is going to be x1 x1
squared plus 2 X 1 plus 1 minus x1
squared so these cancel out and we just
get 2x1 plus 1 then when we go from this
point to this point our change in Y is
going to be x1 square
plus 4 X 1 plus 4 plus 4 minus X 1
squared minus 2 X 1 minus 1 so what is
this going to be equal to this is going
to be equal to these guys cancel out
those guys cancel out 4 X 1 minus 2 X 1
is 2 X 1 and then 4 minus 1 is 3 so plus
3 now let's do the next one when I go
from this Y value to that Y value change
in Y is going to be X 1 squared plus 6 X
1 plus 9 minus minus this guy over here
X 1 squared plus 4 X 1 plus 4 these
cancel out and sorry I have to put the I
have to distribute the negative sign I'm
subtracting this whole thing but a minus
there and a minus negative sign there 6
X 1 minus 4 X 1 that is 2 X 1 and then I
have 9 minus 4 so plus 5 so this is the
change in Y the first change in Y was
that second change in Y is that third
change in Y is that let's do this one
over here so our change in Y is X 1
squared + 8 X 1 plus 16 minus minus this
value over here minus X 1 squared minus
6 X 1 minus 9 I'm distributing the minus
sign that cancels out 8 X 1 minus 6 X 1
is 2 X 1 16 minus 9 is equal to is equal
to 7 so plus 7 so our change in Y is
from here to here is 2x plus 1 right
there 2 X 1 plus 1 then it's 2 X 1 plus
3 then it's 2 X 1 plus 5 and this 2 X 1
plus 7 so what is the change in the
change of Y notice these are not the
same values they're they're they're
increasing I mean and so we're kind of
jumping the gun what is the change
change in Delta Y so if we go from 2 X
plus 1 to 2 X plus 3
if we go from 2 X plus 1 to 2 X plus 3
well if you subtract that from that the
two x's are going to cancel out 3 minus
1 is 2 if you go from 2 X plus 3 to 2 X
plus 5 that once again the two x's
cancel out we've just increased by 2 if
you go from 2 X 1 plus 5 to 2 X 1 plus 7
once again
you're increasing by 2 so for at least
the situation of y is equal to x squared
hopefully it satisfies you there's no
matter which x one you pick as long as
you keep increasing by one and it's
actually true if you increased by any
constant number the change in your Y
values will not be constant notice this
is not that which is not that which is
not that but the different the change in
the change in Y is the change in Y's are
increasing in this example at a constant
rate so this was completely analogous to
what we did here and if you have some
time on your hands you can actually
prove this or show it or kind of prove
you know get comfort with that this will
work for the more general case of Y is
equal to ax squared or ax squared plus
BX plus C or it work for ax squared plus
BX plus C if we increment just by any
arbitrary constant here so you could put
a K 2 K 3 K the algebra gets a little
bit here that's why I didn't do it but
it'll it should still work so hopefully
you found that kind of satisfying